before you get into it you want to
explain why this story means so much
from you you're from california
there's a lot because i'm getting i'm
getting bombarded but people are asking
me what do you think about what happened
what do you think about what happened
what do you think what happened i'm like
i can't send 100 messages to people what
do you think about what happened it's a
lot easier to just do one podcast go
watch it here's what we think would
happen to california so
governor governor newsome gavin newsom
will remain california governor after
handed handily defeating recall attempt
not even close the guardian right
newsome has prevailed in a historic
recall election that had him battling
for his political life in a referendum
on the governor's leadership uh
through the pandemic voters resoundingly
rejected the choice to replace him with
a trumpist republican i got to keep in
mind this is the guardian newsome's most
popular challenge was larry elder a
right-wing radio host who drew
comparisons to the former president and
who attempted to sow baseless doubts
about the election process newsom said
that in voting no on the republican led
recall california said yes to science
they said yes to vaccines they said yes
to women's rights they said yes to
immigrant rights they said yes to
minimum wage the environment our future
we reject the cynicism and bigotry and
chose hope and progress and then if you
saw him give the speech he got emotional
he said trump is claiming there was
voter fraud here this is a very
emotional moment for us he kind of felt
a little bit emotional didn't do any
questions he just walked off right
and by the way numbers wise yesterday
was 67 percent we know bakersfield and
fresno that are both big republican
counties they did not the vote comes in
a little bit later
now it's 63.9 percent
5.8.4 million people voted no on the
recall
3.297 million voted yes on the recall
you got 9.137 million and then there's a
stats on what it's looking like yes
versus the no so first person i'm going
to go to i have thoughts on this but i'm
going to go to you first okay i'm going
to go to you first i'm curious to know
folks if you're watching this
i don't know where your position is i
don't know if you're from california or
not i also want to hear from some of
your thoughts about what you think about
what happened with california but tom
you live in california we spoke
yesterday at four o'clock when i spoke
to tom yesterday tom couldn't even stay
focused for a second by the way he was
nervous the entire time me and mario
were talking i said tom why do you look
so nervous he says today's the day i
said so what's going on i said
everywhere i go i'm hearing all this
stuff so why don't you tell us how you
feel about what happened last night you
know here's how i feel literally i mean
i felt this way last night i feel the
felt this way this morning when i was
leaving california too i literally feel
like your favorite team say you've been
following a team forever and they lose
the super bowl but on that same day your
favorite team loses the nba championship
and the world series and the easter
bunny gets run over by a cement truck
why is that
just because i had hope i mean there's
very little things that you could hold
out hope for right with the grip that
the democrats have and how california
has just literally turned into a
different state all right pat you used
to live there everybody else a lot of
people watching this right now either
live there or visit or it is not the
same state you take a drive anywhere and
you just think you're in an alternate
universe because this is not the
california that was the uh that beckoned
everybody from all over the world and
all over the united states that wanted
to be there so it was very depressing
and i literally i had built up my hopes
i literally thought there was a chance
that this could happen because everybody
i talked to that was a democrat or would
be a traditional california democrat in
a normal world
they're flipping here's the other thing
dash had baseball last night so he was
training from 6 30 to 8.
i voted
like at 7 30.
the lines were down the street at 7 30.
but by 6 30 the la times everybody else
is calling this thing plus with all the
mail-in votes i'm not trying to say you
know that anything you know happened
that shouldn't have happened or there
was any fraud i don't know maybe there
was but how do you call an election that
quickly you do it because you have the
media right in your back pocket they'll
do whatever they want it's the la times
it's just it's unbelievable how they
were gearing up for this three or four
days in advance saying that it was going
to be a wipeout trying to get people not
to go to the polls
so it was depressing for me because i
liked larry elder i liked what he stood
for i think he made a couple mistakes
pat i don't think he got personal with
gavin newsom like he should have i think
he all he was talking about was uh
policy and what he was going to do he's
not an experienced politician he should
have got in there because he had plenty
of ammunition where he could have buried
some on some personal things just like
newsom did to him
so that's how i'm feeling today i'm a
little bit bummed but i'm an optimist uh
i'm always looking for the silver lining
and here's it for me we've got the super
bowl coming up in february we got the
world cup and we've got the olympics all
coming to la you cannot put on these
types of shows on the global stage and
have your your backyard be a garbage
dump which is basically what l.a it's a
very good southern california yeah
that's a very very good point you just
made yep so you so if those things are
coming to you
and they're talking about a shutdown
because of vaccine mandates you know
they just announced today bars movies
restaurants all the places you're going
in la you're required to show a
your vaccine passport to go into these
places they do that we'll just announce
today okay so how do you how do you run
those events
well you know you you do the facelift
right you clean the homeless off the
street near inglewood where the super
bowl is going to be in the new stadium
or downtown or even if you watched the
sunday night game last night they showed
all the beauty shots of la during the
season opener for the rams on sunday
night but for the world cup in the
olympics it's going to be different
because that's the world converging on
your city and it's two and a half or
three weeks or even a month so
i don't know i mean i knew it was going
to come of course and then there's going
to be payback right because newsome's
going to take it personally that they
even tried to get him out so he's going
to he's going to bury us under his thumb
even worse
i'm scared i have an opinion opinion on
this or no you seem quiet of course tell
us what you guys seem quiet because i'm
listening to tom's enter cry over here
you're all right bro
how the hell would you feel i don't know
i mean i'm not from california i've
never dealt with a recall like this i
feel like this this is a california
thing how many other states are having
recalls your boy george will who was a
uh would you say mentor or what what
would you say he's not a mentor i would
say he was a wonderful thought leader of
yours yeah he was one of the first ones
that influenced you know he was on uh
bill maher recently yeah last week and
he
conservative right i don't know if i put
him as a conservative he's a hundred
percent a conservative but he's not a
trump conservative he's not a magazine
he's a not a maggot
he's a lincoln project guy sure yeah
okay that's a conservative though but
they're currently they don't know if it
is to be honest with you we can go off
the rails here i don't even know what a
conservative is at this point i don't
think it matters anyway
i don't even know what it means
and right of republican and democrat of
liberal and conservative that they're
just words at this point well we i do
agree with you on that what we have
emerging are two very very clear camps
you have the collectivists and you have
the individualists you you have the
globalists and the federalists and that
that's what's really emerging that's a
better way of putting it i agree but i
don't think i i i would vent i would
venture to guess that 50 percent of the
people could not define any of those
words he just used yeah it's very
collectivist means what well so what is
the best we're all going to do this
right so so professor i heard a
professor from cornell university said
what makes capitalism work
and what makes this work in companies
and what backfires on companies is you
have to be able to pump up the
collective
but make sure you individually recognize
the individuals above and beyond
everybody else which means what the team
wins a championship you can say you
can't say oh we did this all together it
wasn't because of one person no here's
how a football game ends with gang great
job defense great job offense phenomenal
job but the game ball goes to
america's not doing game ball anymore
america is just doing we won we forgot
about the game ball that's what he's
saying collective but go ahead you're
gonna make up not about california look
being from florida we don't have the
divisive politics that you guys have in
california this is something that i've
learned since being at valuetainment
even new jersey like gerard has very
strong feelings against uh
the
don't say his name we're having a good
so to your boy phil murphy whatever his
name is very strong feelings you have
very strong feelings
uh against
gavin newsom in florida we're just like
look we're purple state
look we'll get along we'll not get along
it's fine it's all good i'll see you at
the club it's not that big of a deal
obviously in california it's a very big
deal but i'm not shocked by this i think
what i'm most shocked at is the fact
that i've been
spoon-fed this gavin newsom's out of
here for the last year and dude it
wasn't even close 67 it wasn't even
close
like we've been we've been whether it's
the topics we cover whether it's the
people that are on the show whether it's
who's who said he's he's going to be out
who said who has said he's going to be
out no just it's just been a theme that
we've been discussing that gavin
newton's
the bottom line is this it wasn't close
uh two to one margins is the exact same
margin to you what does that doesn't
mean anything california there's no no
you have to know that it has to mean
something that there's two to one
democrats in california california's
democratic state right nice try larry
elder wasn't happening the closest thing
they had to republican recently was the
governor screw your freedoms arnold
schwarzenegger yeah the point is this
i thought this would be a lot closer
because of the stuff that i'm hearing
around us but it wasn't even close had
it been 10 points
20 points whatever
it wasn't even a close situation before
gerard i'm trying to see if you're
trying to make a point bro like
tell me the point is it wasn't close i
know but what does that mean why did we
think it was going to be close no it's
not about okay so why isn't it closed
tell me why it's not closed because
democrats
everything was voted around political
lines
would you not agree that that california
is not is the the most or if not the
biggest democratic state in the country
top five yeah blue estate okay some
would say number one so why are we
shell-shocked on this meaning why why
i'm not saying we why were you
shell-shocked well here obviously
because you spoke to some friends that
thought that oh god i lived there it's a
big it's not gonna be like yeah exactly
but look here like you're like oh my god
the easter bunny got run over it's like
no
we all saw this coming yeah but he
wasn't getting homeless
on every street around you and what la's
turned into you'd take it a little bit
more personally here's a quick fight
of what you asked
um adam right now is the here's what it
tells me the democrats have a game plan
and an agenda when it comes to an
election they attack they rally they do
whatever it takes to win and they're
successful at it but obama was cutting
tv commercials all right biden was in
long beach on monday night they rallied
together whether they're telling you the
truth or not they have a message they
stick to it and they're ruthless and the
republicans don't play that way i
respect it yeah the republicans haven't
picked up that play card yet let me say
one thing and then i want to get
george's thoughts here are the biggest
issues in california let me ask you let
me ask a question who from the
republican side showed up to california
to help larry elder not one damn person
give me one name show it up to
california i can't think of one
that's the point zero zero and larry
elder's so articulate because he's a
broadcaster that he can carry a message
by himself and he's likeable and on
paper how could you not love the guy but
no one showed no one showed no one no
one showed up but that's on the
republicans i can't get mad at the
democrats
i fully agree exactly
what we talked about today you said the
best ability is your availability yeah
obama made himself available you might
have made himself available i agree
complimenters are available who made
themselves available no debate that's
why i'm not sure
here's what they said the biggest issues
were for the voting bloc first and
foremost not even close was covent 31
number two like you said homelessness 22
percent the economy taxes 16
top three
wildfires in california big deal 14
and then number five crime eight percent
yeah and all reasons
i i can't believe it turned out by the
way okay so to your point
they asked how's california doing with
covet
percent said it's getting better 40
30 said staying the same 24 said it's
getting worse so to your point they're
actually happy with the job he's doing
no no no no no no no no that's not wait
a minute read that number again go back
how's he doing you said 40 said it's
getting better better 30 said what it's
staying the same and 20 said what it's
getting worse what's a bigger number 50
or 40.
staying the same staying the same and 20
is not a possibility it's not getting
worse no no but you don't understand
staying the same is not a positive thing
to vote for
staying decent and who are they talking
to they're talking to teachers outside
of a user home so let me give let me
give let me give my my take here well
the polling shows that he won so what
are we talking about not he won he
destroyed exactly this by the way this
is like this is like 48 to
you know two touchdowns this was an ass
weapon well buddy it's not even close so
here's a couple things here's a couple
things one
is anybody surprised
guys are texting me and the only answer
i'm giving is why are you surprised why
are you surprised tell me why you're
surprised okay
one on a recall does he have to debate
anybody no no
can he use the government funds to help
him win the recall yes or no yes you
know how much money he spent of
taxpayers money to help him 200 million
80 million dollars that dinner cost him
80 million bucks
larry elder doesn't have that kind of
money which means what makes you think
the right guy won it's the guy with more
money and more pull one it's not the
right guy in every politics but let's
continue let's continue let's continue
let's continue second third part
there is no debate for me to sit against
this guy to really be able to weigh him
out so that's just not going to be
taking place right i mean we covered a
little bit earlier but there's no debate
i didn't see
larry elder's policies going up against
his policies there was nothing like that
we did not see a single debate because
that's how the system is set up right
okay fine let's continue
what does this mean with obama biden all
of those guys showing up what does it
mean
hey republicans just so you know
that picture with you
bush obama everybody together
saying bush is now changing his legacy
because he keeps throwing trump under
the bus
guess what you're indirectly doing
you're doing exactly what they want you
to do for them to win because they are
united and they have somebody from the
other side on their side which means
republicans are confused if i'm a
republican and if i go out say i'm a big
governor republican i go out and i
support larry elder am i indirectly
being seen as being a pro-trump guy
because larry elder is a pro-trump guy
yes okay that's what i'm saying so yeah
so your advisor has a governor who's got
you know election coming up you're
sending your advisors saying listen i'll
skip this one i probably wouldn't go to
this one if i were you just kind of stay
home dude you don't need to do this who
cares if california we don't get nothing
from california so i'm not going right
okay go to the next part so obama biden
those guys kamala go pelosi they all
support him fantastic phenomenal job
when is the last time california has a
republican uh governor when's the last
time
that's not a republican that's he was a
republican he's not a republican okay
like a trooper maybe he's a rhino no
he's a republican
part of the party he ran as a republican
not a republican
but he's not a republican he's a
celebrity meaning he's a celebrity that
ran as a republican he's not a
republican he's not a republican is true
he's not a republican the first
independent president we ever had was
donald trump he's not a republican don't
get it twisted the guy had to run as a
republican ticket not an independent
ticket so arnold is probably an
independent he ran as a republican
ticket he's not a republican you don't
win as a republican okay just like
kevin that came over here meet kevin he
ran as a what democrat but he's not a
democrat he's probably an independent
but he can't win on an independent 51 49
democrat i say he's an independent but
strategically he made the right choice
to run as a democrat basically you're
saying people are independent you've got
to pick
california had a republican governor was
probably wilson or the armenian uh
governor that they have duke medjan i
think that's his last name pete duke
that was an armenian governor i went to
a couple events uh in his later years so
so the last time they had governor
republican was quite some time ago what
does that mean for me for california
what are the chances
of a republican person winning in
california the next eight years let's
see let's process that together and kind
of go through it all right
number one
how many people
watch this year watch the angle i'm
going to take with this how many people
like tom
didn't leave california because they
were hopeful that a larry elder or
somebody would flip the recall would
happen and they're not leaving
california because let's face it there's
not a state in america that has better
weather than california if you take
regulation
the way that you handle covid and taxes
out there's not a state that competes
with california take governing out if
you take
you know if you take governing out i'm
telling you right now there's no weather
and that's what comes that's california
no weather comes florida's closed no no
no no i don't collect i don't think it's
they're two different climates that's
the mediterranean but i tell you i i
choose i choose california one i just
florida number two just so you know but
to me it's a very close but i still put
california at the time and i'm not even
living in california i'm in florida
right now but here's what just happened
this is the part where i don't think
republicans are going to win there for a
long time okay
for eight years i think it's got to get
very painful before something happens
here's my prediction
my prediction is
those who are on the tipping point
they officially booked their tickets
now booking their tickets could be 90
days could be six months could be two
months oh yeah yeah could be 18 months
could be 24 months but how many husbands
and wives had a conversation last night
saying babe what are we doing i remember
when i had my conversation business
owner i left in 20 i left in what year i
left in uh
i left california
what is it like uh uh we came here
when february of 2021 so go back five
years as well 2016. we left february 1st
of 201 2016 right do you know when i
know i was leaving california
2013 maybe i was in woodland hills in my
office a guy knocked on my door said i'm
here to collect taxes i said what he
said i'm here to collect taxes what kind
of taxes i pay my state taxes i pay my
federal taxes what he he says it's
county taxes i said wait what are you
talking about he says yes county taxes
we hear that you're doing well we
obviously follow your stuff we hear
you're making money you have to pay your
account
you're making i'm not even kidding with
you this guy comes and gives me his
business going like this is
fraud yeah i go to eighth floor my uh my
uh what do you call it my accountant who
were on that floor i said what is this
all about it says they got you it's
hit and miss they barely get any
business but when they do got to pay up
i have to pay this is yet so you know
it's nearly eighty thousand dollars this
is that's two employees i can't say you
gotta pay that eighty thousand dollars
so i said okay i'm gonna move to i'm
gonna move to glendale because there's
13 counties that don't have la what do
you call it county taxes burbank's one
of them bourbon glendo because of
hollywood burbank was one of them i
think santa monica is one of
victorville's one of them anyways the
lens i think some of these guys are won
like 13 counties so i move
every time i moved more stuff was coming
up in 2012 i told morale and i told jen
brace for impact we're probably going to
end up in texas morale laughed at me
jennifer said babe i'm not going back to
texas and she's from texas
so we ended up in texas three years
later i'm telling you right now
god knows how many people booked their
ticket out yesterday yeah and i'll tell
you the only timeline is we don't know
when it could be 90 days it could be six
months it could be 24 months but it's
tens of thousands that believe in
capitalism that believe in freedom of
choice of choosing what i do with my
body okay and i'm not talking about the
abortion i'm talking about what i want
to do like nicki minaj type of freedom
it's people that just want to be left on
it's libertarians it's independent it's
republicans that are sitting there
saying can i really live with this for
another four to eight years and it's not
the fact that you can live with
democrats that's not the issue there's
many states that are okay there's two
states maybe three states that are going
above and beyond four new york is one
it's probably a handful new york's one
the other one is what california so if
if they thought like oh mass exodus
you just saw the people that are patient
who sat around that are saying you push
me a little bit too much so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]